miss Conliffe is a Mellon postdoctoral
fellow here at MIT and where she's
researching the social political
cultural dimensions of urban climate
change adaptation in the spray she's
going to be teaching the course you're
not teaching this but in the spring
you're teaching course called media and
climate change it is yes it is even if
it weren't you could always take it up
for the grad students in the room as an
independent study system okay but anyway
I encourage you to take a look at that
class they're looking for and elected
for the spring currently liz is writing
her first book which is called retreat
moving to higher ground in a climate
change city it's under contract with the
University of Chicago Press
congratulations an excellent press and
you know one of the things I like about
colloquium is that we bring in people at
a lot of different stages of their
career we had actually if someone
recently out of undergrad from MIT but
more often it'll be somewhere at school
somewhat mid-career often has two
speakers have been senior scholars and
so I think in addition to the specific
research that Lisa's presenting today
I'm sure she would be amenable to
answering questions about well how do
you change a dissertation into a book or
or any kind of school you know school
work into publishable work what are some
of the issues there so feel free to ask
her questions about that retreat her the
book that she's working on is based on
field work that she did in Staten Island
for four years after Hurricane sandy
where residents elected to relocate in
favor of Richard and in return the
waterfront neighborhoods to wetlands
rather than rebuilding and given her
interesting climate change and
hurricanes and flood maps and FEMA this
feels like a particularly urgent moment
to be talking about these kinds of
issues and I suspect that she could
answer questions related to the present
crisis moment in hurricanes and
and so on in addition to speaking
specifically about hurricane sandy
before coming to MIT Liz received a PhD
in media culture and communication from
NYU an MSC in culture and society from
the Department of Sociology at the
London School of Economics and a BA in
communication in Spanish and Latin
American literature from George Mason
George Washington University so thank
you so much Heather thank you all for
coming out this afternoon
evening to hear this talk and as Heather
said I'll be presenting some research
from my dissertation but then some new
newer material that's also from that but
it's material I haven't presented before
and I'm still really working through so
I'm looking forward to our conversation
and to hearing your thoughts and and all
of that I know for those of you who have
an abiding interest and climate change
in hurricanes Kerry Emanuel is giving a
talk at 6:30 and MIT so some of you
might be trying to go to that so I won't
I'll kind of dive dive right in no pun
intended
you don't realize until you're writing
about water how much how many water
watery metaphors there are everywhere so
I'll speak for maybe 30 to 40 45 minutes
and then leave a lot of time for for
discussion and questions okay so on
October 29 2012 hurricane sandy struck
the east coast of the United States and
I know Heather was saying you remember
that night vividly probably a number of
us here remember that night vividly in
New York City where I was living at the
time the borough of Staten Island was
particularly hard-hit this is the
neighborhood on the east shore Staten
Island at the highest recorded water
levels in the city it had the most
deaths in the city and it had the
greatest proportion of residents
affected of any borough and
neighborhoods like this one have
suffered repeated flooding over the
years and my research works to
understand what will happen to these
neighborhoods and to others like them as
climate change increases the risks that
they already
and this in turn requires understanding
how things like risk climate change
impacts of climate change such as
flooding or mediated and that will be
some of what I speak about today
now climate change is necessarily
mediated Paul Edwards has a wonderful
book called a vast machine and he points
out in that book that climate is the
history of weather so like other forms
of history climate can't be perceived
directly our scientific understanding
and knowledge of climate change and the
global climate generally relies on what
Edwards calls a climate knowledge
infrastructure and that's made up of
model data of technical systems
institutions such as the IPCC the
Intergovernmental Panel on Climate
Change and so on and so this graph is
one one product of that infrastructure
and it likely looks familiar to many of
you it shows average global temperature
increasing at an unprecedented rate
tracking carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere so even even if the
powers-that-be stopped burning fossil
fuels right now carbon dioxide stays it
lingers in the atmosphere it continues
to have a warming effect for upwards of
a century after its release so what this
means is that even as we work to
mitigate climate change by cutting
greenhouse gas emissions we also have to
work to adapt to the impacts that are
already baked into the system and enough
there's been enough kind of warming
locked in to ensure substantial
disruption to everyday life in many
places now data models and Technology
are becoming more more sophisticated
more powerful and fine-tuned so this has
made it possible to measure climate
change and its effects on more local
levels as well and to create more local
level predictions well this graph is
from the latest report of the New York
City Panel on Climate Change and it
shows that average annual temperatures
is measured in Central Park in New York
have increased three point four degrees
Fahrenheit since 1900 in this area I was
looking up trends for Boston because I
realized
having lived in New York for until until
this summer my talk is kind of New York
centric so trying to make it more more
Boston and Cambridge specific there was
a very interesting report called the
climate ready Boston report that was
released this past December and it notes
here summers by 2050 may be as hot as
Washington DC's summers are today and by
the end of this century they may be
hotter than Birmingham Alabama's summers
are today in Boston this is another
graph from the New York City report and
it shows that there's already been one
foot of observed sea-level rise is
measured at the battery in lower
Manhattan over the past century so this
is a foot of sea level rise that's
already happened and a foot doesn't
sound like that much but this extra foot
of water is estimated to have added
approximately two billion dollars to
Sandy's toll in New York City and to
have flooded an extra 100 thousand
people in New York and New Jersey who
would not have flooded without that
extra foot of water so it makes a big
difference now I'm in New York Harbor
along much of the eastern seaboard sea
levels are rising it more than double
the global average rate this is due to a
number of factors ocean currents wind
patterns the the diminishing
gravitational pull of melting ice caps
that right now are kind of pulling the
sea up towards the poles and also land
that's also subsiding so the land in
this part of the country is sinking
and rates of sea-level rise are
increasing exponentially and they'll
continue to do so if emissions continue
unabated this is an image I took from
Planet central surging C's website which
I really recommend going to and kind of
playing around with it lets you set a
lot of different scenarios and see what
see what comes out and this this map
shows projected inundation in Cambridge
in Boston if global average temperature
increases 1.5 degrees Celsius so that's
an amount that some would argue is
already locked in now we're warming to
increase to two degrees the long term
sea level rise could change the map of
this area to something like this so this
is the difference 1.5 - that's 3 degrees
and that's 4 degrees which most
resembles the kind of track that we're
currently on in terms of our emissions
any one of these scenarios even even the
lowest emission scenario still promises
a huge amount of disruption but what
this will look like depends not only on
the extent of warming and its effect but
also on the ways that those effects and
their attendant risks are measured and
mapped and managed and that will be the
focus of the talk now practices of
remapping and rezoning land based on
environmental risk have been rapidly
expanding worldwide you get maps like
these that visualize everything from
mosquito vectors to landslide risk and
and they become coal if 'ok enough to
constitute a new cartographic genre
those are the words of map historian
mark mon Munir he has some great great
work on risk and hazard maps
specifically and so I'll quote from him
now acceptance of cartographic
simulation and risk assessment as normal
and necessary
he writes may prove his monumental a
turning point in public administration
as the acceptance centuries ago of
boundary Maps without which land
ownership taxation and zoning would be
impossible
so the questions this raises are what
are the stakes of this emerging genre of
maps what kinds of things do they afford
how are they made how are they used how
are they experienced and how are people
contesting them and you know from my
point of view at a moment when climate
change is rendering any kind of notion
and fixed or stable landscape
increasingly untenable what role can
maps play and helping us navigate a
profoundly uncertain and contingent
future so these are big questions and I
will only just start exploring them
today and to do that I want to take you
back to Staten Island after sandy and
tell you the story of an encounter with
one very particular but very powerful
set of maps so this this is a photo of a
neighborhood called Oakwood Beach also
on Staten Island's East Shore for those
of you familiar with New York City up in
the top left corner you can just make
out the outline of the verrazano-narrows
bridge that connects Staten Island to
Brooklyn and then further beyond that is
lower Manhattan so in this this image
you can see houses that were swept
entirely off their foundations into the
surrounding wetlands by a storm surge
that was more than 14 feet the night of
sandy sandy was not the first time that
Oakwood Beach was devastated by a storm
in 1992 a nor'easter flooded the
neighborhood and it led a group of
residents there at a forum what they
called the Oakwood Beach flood victims
committee so this group of residents got
together and they spent years lobbying
for better coastal protection and for an
end to new development in the wetlands
but little came of their efforts and
then 20 years after this nor'easter
sandy hits sandy killed three people in
Oakwood Beach which is a very close-knit
neighborhood and it was the final straw
for many many residents there one week
after the storm this letter to the
editor appeared on the website of Staten
Island's daily newspaper and the author
Tina downer she was a longtime resident
Oakwood Beach and she wrote about her
years living in the neighborhood she had
been a member of this original flood
victims committee and she wrote that she
deeply loved her neighborhood and loved
living there but she decided after sandy
that it was no
longer a safe place to live not long
after Tina's letter appeared she helped
organize a community meeting for her
neighbors to get together and discuss
their their collective future more than
200 people showed up at that meeting and
to Tina's surprise until the surprise of
others present they voted nearly
unanimously to pursue a buyout of their
homes so this meant as Heather mentioned
that rather than stay and rebuild and
keep fighting indefinitely for flood
protection that might never really come
they wanted the government to pay them
enough money to relocate and then to
return their neighborhood to wetlands
that could provide some kind of
protective buffer for their neighbors
further inland so this is what's known
as managed retreat relocating people and
unbuilding of land in places vulnerable
the flooding sea level rise and other
effects of climate change and after that
meeting when they realized the kind of
overwhelming interest in a neighborhood
buyout some members is that original
flood victims committee and some others
President created a new committee that
they called the Oakwood Beach by out
committee and they created a plan and
they started pushing it to local city
and state officials and so this time
they were successful less than three
months later in New York state's
Governor Andrew Cuomo came down to
Staten Island and he announced to
support for a pilot by out of that
neighborhood he said homeowners who
opted to participate in the program
would be paid the pre-storm value of
their damaged houses and you saw the
condition of some of these houses
totally totally gone and that the state
would then return the properties to open
space and prohibit any future
development in those places so when new
news of the Oakwood Beach buy out broke
at first it seemed like an anomaly even
in places with recurrent disasters and
even in that kind of New York New Jersey
region after sandy people generally do
not relocate they decide to rebuild in
place and post disaster policies are
geared towards rebuilding rebuilding
homes and infrastructure where they were
before
but before long I watched as residents
in other neighborhoods along Staten
Island's Shore began organizing their
own local buyout committees pressing the
state to expand its program to include
them too this is a picture I took in the
neighborhood of ocean breeze that's just
up the shore from Oakwood Beach I think
you can probably read the sign from
there before the audio sake I'll read it
governor cuomo ocean breeze needs your
buy out three exclamation points once
the picture I took at a meeting in
Crescent Beach says Governor Cuomo
desperate will work for buyout and this
is in South Beach one of the signs reads
Governor Cuomo senior sick tired broke
buy me out please and this is from the
neighborhood Graham Beach Governor Cuomo
mother nature wants her land back buy us
out and give it back in the weeks and
months after sandy to use resident
organized by out groups formed all along
Staten Island's east and south shores
you could see Oakwood Beach that first
neighborhood is right in the middle
yeah but not everyone thought that
redrawing the city's coastline in this
way it was a good idea so the mayor at
the time Michael Bloomberg came out
strongly against retreat which he
described as not only futile given the
hundreds of thousands of people who live
in New York City's floodplain but also
was an abandonment effectively at the
waterfront
he said his New Yorkers we cannot and
will not abandon our waterfront we must
protect it not retreat from it rather
than prohibit future development as the
state plan would do Bloomberg proposed
doing the opposite so he created this
housing recovery program called build it
back aptly named that offered homeowners
who wanted to relocate roughly the same
amount of money as a buyout but the city
would retain the right to flip the land
to developers who promised to rebuild in
a more flood resilient manner so what
happened is you wound up with these kind
of competing government programs
competing visions of what the coast
should look like in the future and the
question was you know how do you
determine which people get to go into
which program how do you decide which
places are risky enough to warrant the
permanent on building that retreat
entails so an obvious solution here's
where we get to to the maps is to use a
risk map and indeed officials initially
proposed to use the flood maps shown
here which are produced by FEMA the
Federal Emergency Management Agency to
determine who would be eligible for
retreat versus redevelopment so these
maps are pretty boring to look at
they're not boring substantively but
like many other official maps they're
probably intentionally boring there any
neutral appearance kind of works to
convey the sense of objectivity
neutrality and they're predominantly
grayscale as you can see and these
matters of little polka dots black and
blue delineate three general flood zones
so you have zones VA and X and V and a
are the ones shaded in blue here and
those to get
make up the special flood hazard area so
this is also called the 100-year
floodplain which probably is a familiar
term because it's kind of come up a lot
in articles after these more recent
storms - and it's a pretty misleading
term the 100-year flood is a very
misleading term because it actually
refers to a flood that has a 1% chance
of occurring in any given year and this
means as FEMA's website kind of points
out that it has at least a twenty six
percent chance of occurring over the
course of a 30-year mortgage it's not
once every 100 years at all so these
it's kind of yeah a misleading term and
the proposal after sandy initially was
that homeowners in zone V so viene have
the same risk of flooding but V is a
kind of additional risk of wind driven
storm surge the B stands for velocity
the velocity zone so they said
homeowners in zone V the highest risk
zone would be eligible to apply for a
state buyout but homeowners in zone a
the other part of the high-risk flood
zone would only be able to sell their
land to the city for redevelopment
so probably very not surprisingly this
was a very controversial way of bounding
retreat and as it the case with most
official boundaries the lines on
thenahms maps transgressed social
boundaries so they divided up streets
they divided up neighborhoods they
divided up in some cases attached houses
and they divided the buyout groups that
had already started organizing and
making their own maps of people in their
neighborhoods who wanted to relocate and
this kind of top-down targeting of areas
for retreat has a very ignominiously
this image was published shortly after
Hurricane Katrina hit New Orleans and it
showed parts of that city that some
planners and officials proposed to be
returned to green space rather than
rebuilt it came to be known as the green
dot map and an in cited a huge amount of
debate infuriated people who were angry
not just at the idea that government
would dictate who could and could not
return to the city and rebuild but also
because this image appeared to target
largely low-income
black neighborhoods to the exclusion of
wealthier wider areas that were still
themselves heavily flooded so people
very much took it as a continuation of
discriminatory Urban Renewal agendas
under the new guise of resiliency
planning and disaster recovery and that
was kind of the story of Katrina across
many aspects of New Orleans and these
these histories of forced relocation and
segregated development have contributed
to what's now very unequal exposure of
people in places to risk him a present
so any risk map also has this social
history underlying it underlying who in
maps and who it affects and risk maps
are very complicit in that history so
probably the most infamous kind of risk
map is a redlining map a neighborhood
risk rating map and obviously we're
still living with the legacies of those
now and so in Staten Island it was very
different many of the hardest hit areas
were made up largely of white working in
middle-class homeowners and residents
there faulted the maps for erasing a
different history and that history was
the historical production of flood risk
over time so there was a time in the
living memory of some of the people who
are still on the shore who when the line
between land and water in these
neighborhoods was much less clear-cut
than it appears now on FEMA's maps that
was a time when the neighborhoods
bungalows sat on pilings and the
wetlands it's an old photo of ocean
breeze and older residents when you talk
to them have memories of you know
catching eels off their docks and
getting into tubes and going all the way
out into the ocean but during their
lifetimes these creeks and wetlands were
filled in and so now they say the water
just has nowhere left to go the
construction of the verrazano-narrows
bridge which I pointed out earlier
connecting Staten Island to the rest of
New York City for the first time in 1964
spurred development all along the shore
and not long after the bridge opened the
National Flood Insurance Act made flood
insurance affordable and easily
accessible and that helps subsidize
coastal real estate development
nationwide make a note of this because I
will I will come back to the National
Flood Insurance Program
in a minute this was true on Staten
Island where new housing started going
up and what had been mainly agricultural
land wetlands were filled in and the
population of the borough soared
exponentially and then flooding got
worse you have more impermeable surfaces
more people and property in the way a
lot of areas don't have any kind of
drainage infrastructure at all but
development kept going up housing was
built at a really in a frenetic and
unplanned pace and here you can see a
new house and a road built right right
in the wetlands that's a pretty common
sight when you get to the end of a road
and then it just kind of dead-ends into
this huge expanse of Phragmites reeds
that grow way higher than your head it's
really odd to feel like you're still in
New York City and then there was more
flooding so now that neighborhood in the
old photo ocean breeze looks like this
and this is not a picture from after
sandy this is just a from what it looks
like after kind of a normal or now more
normal very heavy rainfall and it's not
unusual on a sunny day like this to see
kind of ducks and geese swimming and the
lakes that linger in the middle of these
streets so people will rename they'll
say you know it's Lake kisum or
something instead of kissing Avenue
so really chronic chronic flooding
issues and the bio groups that formed
after sandy were concentrated in these
places that historically used to be
wetlands there's that map again
and these were also the deadliest places
to be in the city during sandy has the
map from WNYC the red dots are people
who died in the storm and it shows that
the highest concentration of deaths was
in this part of the shore that residents
call the bowl this includes ocean breeze
and they call it the bowl because now
there's a Waterfront Boulevard that runs
between these neighborhoods and divides
them from the ocean and that Boulevard
has raised about ten feet above sea
level
and so the streets behind it sit much
lower and what happened in Sandy is the
water rose fairly slowly but then when
it over top that Boulevard it rushed
into those neighborhoods and filled them
up rapidly which left people very little
time to escape
so of course human caused climate change
is also contributed to the production of
flood risk over time the risk in these
areas is not the same as it was when
when the older residents were we're
living there when they were younger the
buyout groups in Staten Island which is
the city's most conservative borough
really focused on the story of the past
that I just related here they would say
you know don't
it's not about kind of effect of climate
change coming in the future you need to
go back and understand this story to
understand why we want to move and they
argue that these places weren't safe to
live not even well no certainly not
because of future climate change
necessarily not even because of the
present impacts of Sandy but because of
these historic development decisions
that placed blame very squarely on
government justified that I'm pursuing
this government by out of their homes so
these are a couple of quotes from people
I spoke to one says the city allowed
development they allowed them to fill in
the creeks and the wetlands a big part
of me says they did this this is a
problem that was created people spoke of
their neighbors we've been fighting for
years as with the Oakland Beach group to
get better protection and they said you
know my heart breaks for someone who
really thought and had the foresight to
see that these things can happen but no
one was listening until the storm now
FEMA's maps by contrast you know they
depict
flood risk is very much or the static a
natural attribute of a place
a kind of dynamic and escalating result
of human action or decisions that are
made from afar and they also reverse the
relationship between citizens and
government as Staten Islanders we're
talking about it
so government by authoring the maps they
become the ones who have the foresight
and are able to kind of predict flooding
and these maps wind up making flood
prone residents themselves personally
responsible at least financially
responsible for that risk and so this is
probably the most controversial aspect
of these maps and this is why they're
controversial not just for people who
wanted buyouts but for people all across
the country including here and that's
because the maps are a product of the
National Flood Insurance Program that I
mentioned before and that is under
written so much development in the
floodplains and along the coast let me
go back to this so if you squint in the
bottom corner here you can make out firm
these maps are officially called firms
that stands for flood insurance rate map
um do any of you own homes and FEMA's
its high up that's great for now so so
if any of you did own homes and had
mortgages and did live in one of FEMA's
flood zones you would be familiar with
the intended use of these maps so their
intended use is to set flood insurance
rates nationwide for the National Flood
Insurance Program and you're required if
you hold a federally backed mortgage and
you're in zones air v you're required to
carry and maintain this flood insurance
so the fact that these maps are a
product of the NFF is relevant not just
in terms of how they represent or
misrepresent the past but also how
they're visualizing the future because
of the congressional mandate they have
to map risks specifically for insurance
purposes
they represent flood risk very
differently than many other kinds of
flood maps that you might see so these
this is a picture I just got off line of
flood maps in the UK which are made by
the Environment Agency there's a great
article about these maps that I'm going
to talk about now as I talk about them
by James Porter and David Emirate and so
they write about how the Environment
Agency makes these flood maps that are
drawn on you know a much larger scale
than the ones I just showed you from
FEMA and that's intentionally so that
they don't affect insurance rates for
individual properties and it also makes
them a lot less expensive to maintain
and to create it's very hard to I mean
you can't map these things perfectly
accurately at all it's a hypothetical
and a third coastline you'd call it but
it's very hard to have anything
approaching any kind of accuracy if
you're at a smaller scale and this has
the added benefit you know from the
Environment Agency's point of view in
the UK of creating uncertainty that's
enough so that when local planning
authorities want to plan a development
or permit of development they're forced
to go to the Environment Agency in the
Environment Agency gets to have a role
in consulting on the project which they
might not have otherwise so they're
created to not be that specific to read
um and the UK maps to as you can see
here there show central London that's
Westminster they show a flood zones as
they would exist without present flood
defences so if those flood defences that
are currently in place like the tongue
flood barrier were to fail and a FEMA's
Maps do not do that in the case of FEMA
maps FEMA certified flood defences such
as levies constructed by the Army Corps
of Engineers change the maps and they
remove areas the defences purport to
protect from the high-risk flood zone in
so that means the people behind those
barriers are no longer required to carry
flood insurance even though you know
they're still living in the same place
and the result this has it may render
the land safe from kind of escalating
flood insurance rates but it remains
very vulnerable of course to the kind of
catastrophic failure you get when those
defenses fail they almost inevitably
fail whether because they're not
adequately maintained like most of the
infrastructure in this country or
because there is an exceptionally strong
event that ends up reaching them so in
the great Midwest floods in the 90s more
than a thousand levees failed along
rivers and of course Hurricane Katrina
and FEMA's Maps also do not take climate
change into account their mandate is
insurance tools is to model present-day
levels of risk based on historic data
and so they're actually not allowed to
incorporate the impacts of climate
change into the maps and as one mapper
explained this to me you know he said I
have a flood insurance policy myself and
even I I make the maps and I don't want
to pay more today based on risk that
someone's projecting in the future that
would not be fair and you know the
future of course is not going to look
like the past the present doesn't look
like the past and you wind up with this
mismatch between past and future
conditions that has become a major issue
for the maps now because they're also
used they're not just used to set flood
insurance rates they're also used to set
building standards building elevation
standards so in the words of the same
FEMA mapper he said you know the problem
is you're using a map that shows today's
risk to tell someone how to build
something that's going to be around for
30 years 50 years and that no longer is
viable because even present conditions
are changing much faster than the maps
can keep up this is a very blurry image
but it shows that in New York City
Sandy's flood water surged far beyond
FEMA's high risk flood zone the orange
is the sandy inundation area and the
blue is the 100-year flood plain from
the FEMA maps that were currently in
effect which dated actually the
1983 so not that not that recent and in
sandy more than 21 square miles a
flooded land lay outside both zones a
and V so another reason that residents
who were looking for buyouts were angry
about the use of FEMA's maps to set the
boundaries of the program was that the
maps didn't take Sandy's damage into
account even the new maps don't take
Sandy's damage into account because FEMA
is actually revising its Maps when the
storm hit and this created a huge number
of problems that were unexpected the
revisions were taking place as part of
broader reforms to the National Flood
Insurance Program that were passed kind
of shockingly with bipartisan support
the summer before sandy and these
reforms are set to dramatically increase
the cost of flood insurance in FEMA's
flood zones by removing subsidies on
properties that predate the creation of
the program and predate the creation of
the Maps so when the National Flood
Insurance Program was first created you
know the government didn't want to
create a program that would displace
people on mass who were already living
in vulnerable areas or in the floodplain
so what they did is they built in
subsidies into the program and this also
allowed more people to afford to be able
to buy into the program and then
spreading the risk around but the
program has gotten deeper and deeper and
deeper into debt and so there are a lot
of voices now pushing to raise to get
rid of all those subsidies entirely and
raise premiums to market rates that that
would be many many thousands of dollars
for some people so
suddenly any changes to the maps of much
higher stakes than they even did
initially and those seeking to rebuild
and stay in their homes after Sandy
started arguing that the new maps were
overstating their risk they threatened
to set property values plummeting and to
set off a wave of displacement that
would be far more destructive than any
one disaster not just these pictures are
from New Jersey not just in New Jersey
but all across the country and this is a
very ongoing debate so just weeks after
FEMA released its first preliminary
revised maps which it did shortly before
Oakwood Beach got its buyout Oakwood
Beach's buyout you know they just looked
at the map that residents made they did
not look at these flood maps yeah
because they didn't realize how much the
man there would be for the program there
wasn't the need to kind of parse who
would get it and who wouldn't at that
stage but just weeks after FEMA released
its first maps it released a new version
of new maps that maintained this kind of
expanded 100-year floodplain
but then shrank the highest-risk V zone
within it so this of course is from
Staten Island a Lee newspaper this was
bad news for Staten Islanders that
thought at the time they needed to be in
the V zone in order to have a shot of
getting bought out and it made the map
seem even more political than people
were otherwise arguing them to be so
they started making the opposite case of
the people you saw in the previous slide
so they started arguing the maps were
actually understating their risk because
they knew that unless they could show
sufficient risk they wouldn't get the
support they needed to move and the maps
were still not yet final so they have
remained in flux because New York City
then proceeded to launch its own appeal
of the maps Boston also appealed its
latest one maps I learned on the
internet today so the city launched the
appeal of the maps the city said the
maps are still too severe and so here in
the orange you can see this is what the
city analysis shows they believe the 1%
annual chance flood plain should be and
the purple is what FEMA has been saying
it should be
and it was only late last year just a
few months ago that the appeal was
decided in New York City's favor so this
means that FEMA is redrawing its Maps
yet again and as we approach the five
year anniversary of Hurricane sandy
that's next week these maps and the
reauthorization of the entire National
Flood Insurance Program are still
pending and a worsening climate change
means the maps are likely to just keep
changing again and again again and
probably sooner you know we can't have
another 30 year gap until the maps will
need to change again which is how much
if you might kind of plan to update them
in order to have enough data to work
with so here this shows again if you
can't see this from the New York City
Panel on Climate Change shows and purple
FEMA's preliminary maps that have now
been appealed and will be tinier the
light green is the estimates first what
sea level rise will mean in the 2020s
very soon in 2050 s from the eighties
the red is 2100 and these are very
optimistic projections of sea level rise
that they're using here so for sandy
affected homeowners in Staten Island the
whole process resulted in the state of
limbo where people were waiting to find
out as the maps were changing whether or
not they'd be eligible for a buyout or
if they rebuild how high should they
rebuild how high would they have to
elevate and you know how long was it
until the maps changed again and they
had to elevate again and these are
really high stakes questions because
elevating a home in New York City can
cost up to $10,000 a foot and FEMA's
maps are saying you know you need to
elevate maybe 14 feet 16 feet up so it's
a huge expense and that's the way you
reduce these flood insurance rates that
if you don't elevate you probably can't
afford to pay
so while flood maps such as FEMA's are
intended you know the thought is that
they're supposed to reduce uncertainty
they convert it into measurable risk
that you can do something with in this
case they've simply served to
redistribute that uncertainty and they
shifted it on to individual homeowners
who have very struggled to recover from
the storm let alone plan for the future
in this in this context
so as it turned out only a fraction of
those who organized in favor of retreat
wound up being admitted to the states by
all programs for them you know they're
able to get out of the flood zone for
now they're not these maps are no longer
kind of dictating their their future and
their possibilities but this is a small
number of people and they're people who
will refer to themselves now as the
lucky ones because they're able to buy
themselves a few more years of security
financial security security from
flooding and I should say that the
proposal to use FEMA's maps as
boundaries for the buyout was very very
short-lived it cited a lot of resistance
and it became really clear that you know
this it was not a purpose for which they
could even be used it didn't make any
any sense so there were a lot of other
complicated factors that fed into the
selection of these neighborhoods us and
entirely that would be many other talks
but but the result was still kind of the
same that just a small number of people
became became part this is a cartoon
that one of the buyout group leaders
gave me he was he was one of those lucky
ones he moved out of the flood zone to
high ground and you know he's not the
only one who's trying to buy time in
this context the city the state and the
federal government are also doing what
they can to get a few more years in
recent months the Army Corps of
Engineers has developed yet another
vision of the potential future coastline
and this is a sea wall that would go in
front of all of Staten Island's East
Shore so the same area where residents
were trying to retreat and the wall
would not be that much higher than sandy
storm surge and sandy of course was not
even a hurricane when it actually hit
land so there's a sense among some
residents that the wall is perhaps
obsolete before it's even been built the
walls design takes historic rather than
future rates of sea level rise into
account and I was at one meeting with a
woman where she said it's not history
it's fantasy and everyone sort of not in
an agreement so it's less a wall that's
gonna offer definite protection from the
environmental risk but what it will do
is it's geared to protecting
from the financial risk posed by the
flood maps to the city so the maps will
be amended yet again once the wall is
built to take these places out of the
flood zone so I was trying to fit this
in somewhere I thought it was so
interesting it's from the city's climate
ready Boston report again and it shows
in yellow the 2016 this is the current
shoreline of Boston and Cambridge and
then the white is where the shoreline
was in 1630
so you can see just how much of the city
is built on fill which people who live
here probably already know it was more
than I than I realized so we live in a
world that's been shaped by the maps of
the past and with the proliferation of
Griffes mapping it's increasingly shaped
by the maps of the future battles over
risk maps over how to redraw the
coastline after a disaster or an
anticipation of climate change our
struggles over time as well as space so
that's something I want wanted to convey
in this talk it's about how to represent
the past how to envision the future and
then how to navigate the present and
maybe all maps now in some sense are
becoming more like risk maps because
even those that kind of presume a stable
landscape also hold the presumption that
will act with sufficient urgency to
preserve that landscape in some form
that bears some kind of resemblance to
how it exists in the present and it may
be kind of erroneous to call this talk
mapping climate change because the maps
are spent most of my time discussing do
not take climate change into account as
I said but it's these existing tools and
the associated kinds of theories and
systems political systems financial
systems like insurance prediction
technical system social systems that are
serving to mediate a climate change to
reality now for which they were not
created and this is true of this is true
of media so as you can see this about
probably any discipline or anything that
it's kind of founding theories were
created with the presumption of a stable
climate that doesn't exist so we have to
rethink that and for maps it begs the
question you know what kinds of new maps
new ways of mapping and new ways of
using maps and seeing maps are needed to
navigate this new reality what kinds of
stories will they tell on whose will
they erase
and these are not new questions for
anyone who's in media studies and
studies maps but they're questions that
appear in a particularly urgent at the
present moment and they are the ones
that I will leave you with today that's
a great question it's funny I think
James and I have talked about this
before but you know the area I end up
doing my research in this part of Staten
Island you know most people I spoke to
or older they don't necessarily have
cell phones it's you know the kind of
media I wound up writing about so much
it's like the print newspaper and the
fact that it was still print really
really matter in terms of how people
organized in this place and so beyond to
the sort of maps that I showed you that
people were we're drawing and that that
hasn't come up so much I think it's
something that probably when I'm you
know working on revising this into
something that is publishable and
looking for other sources a lot of them
are talking about kind of crisis mapping
participatory forms and mapping counter
mapping but that wasn't something I saw
so much in my own research
I have three questions which is totally
cheating so-and-so do what you can
the first one is I was just curious if
if there's any discussion about buyouts
in Florida and then we get the recent
hurricane there I was struck by how many
articles that were in newspapers right
afterwards saying basically yeah why do
anyone think you could live in Florida
this is everyone knows that Florida is a
very dangerous place to live in terms of
climate issues even without climate
change issues coming to a head so I was
just wondering feel anything to say
about that um the second question was
about Staten Island and the broader
issue of the sort of politics of maps
because you use the word political a
number of times but not in the sense of
like well conservatives or liberals or
Republicans or Democrats or you know the
ways we often discuss you know politics
and then the sort of directions in which
things were charged and so when I think
of Staten Island of course of strong
reputation in New York City is that this
is absolutely the most conservative
borough right and everyone immediately
snaps to like you know ninety percent of
the cops in New York City live in Staten
Island a commune and you know it's known
for us to be certain community so I'm
just curious as they're pushing for up
the government handout of a buyout is
there any sense of well we are speaking
for working-class Americans as you know
what are the sort of political balances
of that and are they are there
contradictions or there are actually
people identifying as not being
conservatives in Staten Island who are
pulling for this these buyouts the third
and final question which may be a
non-starter is um I was just thinking
about Robert Moses the infamous New York
City planner who much reviled by many
New Yorkers and wondering I mean he
retired I believe it was not long before
the National Flood Insurance Act to 68
maybe in 65 for and I'm curious if the
buildup
Staten Island with a culmination of
things that he had been working on for
20 or 30 years or more or whether it was
the kind of thing that he would have
resisted for any reason because he
generally made choices that were very
detrimental to working-class people and
very helpful to the wealthy that was his
system for building highways and bridges
and so on so I'm just curious if there's
any backstory on Moses that plays into
this thinking about development of sort
of areas oh these are such wonderful
questions I feel like we'll have to
continue you know they're great so the
first question in terms of buyouts in
Florida and there have been I mean I
think especially with Harvey in Texas
there have been a huge number because
there had been I don't know if people
saw that ProPublica article that had
kind of foreshadowed the damage of
Harvey and showed the development really
dramatically and that was just all over
Twitter and it incited and Harvey was
very much framed as a result you know
this is because the city had developed
so much in its floodplain and so there's
been and also because Harris County that
Houston's in had had a buyout program
before Harvey and now there has just
been a surge of interest again and being
part of that buyout program so that's
something I was surprised to find in a
number of places when I was doing
research on buyouts that actually it's
rare that people who want them get them
because the amount of money for them is
very limited it usually requires a
disaster declaration it requires a local
match which means that the city or town
has to chip in 25% of the cost and
usually not only did they not either
want to or have funds to do that it
means that they're losing some of their
tax base and so it tends to get blocked
at that local level right now Houston is
trying to scale up its buyout program
last I saw they'd already gotten 3,000
calls from people who wanted to
participate but it raises really really
tough questions that I think in Florida
are particularly vexing because so much
of the development I mean in places like
Miami Beach is very very luxury
development and that was an issue in
parts of Staten Island to where there
was a neighborhood the neighborhood all
the way at the southern tip of Staten
Island Tottenville
has a number of those small bungalow
still but they're kind of mixed in with
very big kind of waterfront big mansions
and I think from the perspective of
people in government the optics of
buying out a place where it really looks
like a bailout of wealthy homeowners on
the coast is very very tricky and the
opposite end there it's also tricky to
buy out a very very poor place because
the state officials would talk about you
know they didn't want this to be seen as
kind of a slum clearance program or
something like that so so there's kind
of tough optics involved in tough
choices because even in Staten Island
where it's a much more kind of
working-class please people were getting
in some cases you know several hundred
thousand dollars for their house and
there there was some debate about
whether the money should be used that
way and there's a lot of rhetoric now
about well didn't people just choose to
live here you know and ironically is it
this kind of goes into your second
question that's very much you know what
you would think the attitude would be in
these neighborhoods because they are
very right-leaning very libertarian um
and so that was something that really
surprised me that this would be the
place that you'd find really it in my
mind could the forefront of collective
action to adopt a climate change that
would be a place where you know the
voters they're overwhelmingly in this
part of Staten Island voted for Trump so
you know one one way that I think the
contradiction was resolved for some
people is this story of government
culpability for past developments in the
sense was well the government had any
subsidized flood insurance in the first
place these properties wouldn't have
been built so they're just kind of
making amends for a lot of previous
government intervention and this is a
way so that the government can stop
intervening in people's lives and the
coastline once and for all I think that
would be kind of the way that it's
framed in terms of kind of the politics
of buyouts in the situation and it's
funny because you know Staten Island is
actually there there's a great book
about Staten Island called conservative
bastion in the liberal city but that
book is by a political scientists at the
College of Staten Island and they say
actually Staten Island is probably the
healthiest democracy insofar as
basically evenly split in terms of
political parties it's just
overwhelmingly conservative because the
rest of New York you know never ever
elects a Republicans basically
Missa Staten Island's very evenly
divided
in terms of voting this part of Staten
Island is more conservative the North
Shore is very very democratic but even
in these neighborhoods people held
really wide-ranging political views and
so one issue when they were organizing
because they need to have a shot at
getting bought out they had to get
everyone in the neighborhood to agree
and so that was why you know even if you
privately are concerned about climate
change you probably won't frame a buyout
that way when you're persuading your
neighbor to go because it's something
that could cause dissensus at a time
when people were trying to not so any
kind of conflict and in neighborhoods
where people would sometimes say you
know because I would ask people in other
buyout programs there are precursors for
communities moving altogether and so I
would say hypothetically if that were an
option would you want to move somewhere
along with your neighbors from a
sociological perspective and that's that
seems very important and some people
would say yeah you know I hate my
neighbors don't care but it was tricky
you know because I think people really
didn't want to bring party politics into
it when they were organizing in this way
um but that kind of that whole issue is
something I'm trying to write about now
because it's you know it's something
that it's gonna take a lot of thinking
through a night since the election I've
had so many people say oh you're doing
one of those Trump voter projects and I
was like well I never thought of it like
that before but now you know and then
this kind of also connects to to Robert
Moses so Robert Moses is the one who
actually built that waterfront Boulevard
that was responsible in some ways for
for a lot of the deaths and part of you
know the Verrazano Bridge and the plans
that he had made for coming off it is
this the Staten Island Expressway and
that's what divided Staten Island's
North Shore from the east and south
shores and some people on Staten Island
will call it Staten Island or New York
City's mason-dixon line because Cena's
you know it's always been very very
there's been a huge amounts of housing
discrimination including Trump owned
properties in Staten Island you see the
south and east shores the shore
less so now with the south shore like
vastly majority white in the North Shore
high you know much more like the rest of
New York
and so that I'm not going to divide
reflected self and kind of the movements
that emerged after understanding to will
be building and the conversations about
rebuilding and the different parts the
island but one thing that you talk about
of course of researchers was upset its
Manhattan you know there was obviously
major flooding in Manhattan Manhattan is
a is a fairly densely populated remember
and I had many friends you know they
kind of Lower East Side stuff of it like
the buildings were too booby flood and
you saw pictures of subway stations on
this one of the you know here what if
anything you learned in your research
about things changing in that happen how
these things see and I also wanted to
sort of I just question the way that you
phrase that the maps are pushing the
burden onto individuals and and you've
that specific kind of term because I
mean my skepticism about that particular
way of phrasing it would be you know we
live in a environmental world of social
relationships that are you know I mean
structured through capitalist system
through the state through laws and you
know ideology about those things and so
it seems like you know it's not a map
that's doing it in other words you know
like according to like an alarm system
you would rather have an alarm go off
more times than too few times right and
so similarly you would think that you
know a priori
you that the map should should tell you
what your risk is like in the worst case
scenario and including climate change
and including you know there's more of
these areas that we you know potential
risk zones that could be reasonable
rather than fewer but then we live in a
you know and but it seems like just when
you're talking about development this
kind of letting fair capitalism messes
things up and then of course you have
the Shock Doctrine and we climb after
the thing happens and then it back
screws everything up in it which is like
capitalism and individualized risk is
such a huge part of what you know
creates problems and I guess I want to
know what you think some of the
solutions are and I mean I personally
and you know right I think you put that
really really well and I think yeah
exactly so it's not right it's not the
maps it's right this whole system behind
I mean it's the system that like makes
the city want to appeal them it's the
system that makes North Carolina's ban
looking at sea level rise projections
when you're thinking about development
because there's this huge fear that
you'll have disinvestment you'll have
this kind of collapse of the entire
system of the economy as it's currently
constructed rests on and local
government mean you see so in other
boroughs in Brooklyn right now there's
this plan to build this waterfront
transit line that's right in the flood
zone but in some way City you know it's
dependent to fund flood protection on
getting more development that's what's
gonna fund the protection so you're in
this really kind of sick cycle that it's
hard to break out of keeping things as
they stand and there's definitely I mean
just in terms of buyouts or some
discussion of thinking about how do you
change kind of local governments
dependence on property taxes that seems
like it kind of has to happen but yeah
it would require a really you know
wholesale wholesale change but right
it's not it's not the maps I mean I had
I talked to a friend of mine a colleague
a few years ago about this and he was
saying well
about the flip maps and all it's about
it's about the data it's about the
insurance rates and people are not mad
about the maps they're mad about how
much money the maps are making them pay
and and that's true and then I was
thinking well why you know why did the
maps seem so important here and I guess
part of it is you know their role kind
of the opposite is their role in
facilitating this collective resistance
because you have seen people across the
country who are now identifying as kind
of flood zone communities organizing
these kind of mass movements against
against the rates and I would notice
them I would go to meetings people will
never ask you like how much insurance
how much do you pay for insurance it's
sort of one of those money questions
that people did not ask but every time I
sat down to be meeting people would say
are you zoning or beat you know what is
there one are you in and then you have
this kind of shared thing and so I think
the maps are important in that way of
creating that sense of a collective yeah
I agree with everything that you said
Manhattan yeah so I think you know the
thing that you'll hear over and over
again is like well no one's gonna
retreat from Manhattan no one's gonna
retreat from it just seems unimaginable
because you can imagine picking up a
house in Staten Island and moving in and
even elevating it but what do you do
with kind of skyscrapers and the density
of lower Manhattan and I think you know
in some sense like a self-fulfilling
prophecy because the places that are the
most of the most economic value are the
ones that there's going to be investment
in protecting the wealthiest areas so
you know you saw after after sandy there
were proposals to do sea walls built
under the Verrazano Bridge that would
protect lower Manhattan maybe but would
displace water and flood out parts of
Brooklyn and Staten Island that's
happening you know the Louisiana coastal
master plan there are certain areas that
are included in protections other areas
that are left out of the protections
that are these kind of sacrifice zones
and in a different different way but
Manhattan has I was I was involved in
the rebuild by design competition I
don't know if you've heard about that it
was this kind of federally funded in
Rock
funded initiative after sandy to design
ways of rebuilding the region that we
could be kind of scaled and reproduced
and it tried to take a sort of
innovative approach where instead of
having design teams kind of come in and
propose things for a place they didn't
know they had to apply to be teams with
kind of community groups and they
couldn't have they had to spend months
doing kind of mini ethnographies in
places where they wanted to work before
they even came up with any idea for a
project so tried to kind of flip the
process you know with like I mean now
there were some very interesting
projects that were selected that in the
implementation stage they can't
necessarily build in the way people
wanted them to be build but the one that
got the most funding is this kind of
seawall to go around
Laura Manhattan called the big you I
don't think it's still called the big u
because only one portion of it got
funded so it's now called the Eastside
coastal resiliency project and it was a
big deal that they picked that part of
it to be built with the funding they had
because you might expect that the kind
of wealthier lower west side areas would
be the ones that we've protected first
but there was a real desire to protect
the public housing that's there although
the concern is for people who are living
there and not in public housing without
some kind of rent controls in place
those people could get priced out
through this kind of gentrifying effect
that any kind of protection also can
have so it's another tricky situation
but that's what's happening in
developers who these properties yeah
that's that's like a very live question
there's a the Sabin Center at Columbia's
law school it's the Sabin Center on
climate change law I went to talk there
and I think these are things that are
not resolved so there were a few
different cities in California that have
just sued fossil fuel companies I
believe for to pay and they want them to
pay for the kinds of protections they'll
need to adapt to climate change one of
the Alaska Native villages Kivalina the
many many you know I think back in 92 to
relocate because of coastal erosion and
melting permafrost they haven't been
able to get funding to do that and they
tried suing fossil fuel companies for
the cost of the relocation they weren't
successful but I think there will be
more lawsuits like that and I think at
the last talk I went to it Sabin they
were talking about Heather had been a
suit maybe in Chicago or in the Midwest
where I think the city had been sued for
permitting development that was in a
known floodplain so it's not something
that I think will be the next kind of
big area to look at is how is the law
gonna deal with these questions you can
imagine a lot of Staten Islanders will
talk about in legal terms they like I
just want some liability it's like
negligence law just give me you know the
property and yeah I think I'm interested
in
yeah that's a great question I'm glad
you said you can say no because I have
to say that you know I have given a lot
of talks at my work I've never given a
lot of parts at this talk because I've I
think only once ever for 15 minutes
presented to a media studies audience
those are not the kinds of invitations
and audiences I get asked to speak to so
this was really really daunting for me
to think about wow it's so strange
because I've come out of this Media
Studies program and I'm trading a kind
of communication cultural studies and so
rarely do I ever
am I ever asked to frame my work in that
way so and yeah so it's something I'm
still really kind of figuring out in my
my dissertation chair was a sociologist
he was not a Media Studies so that's
kind of put me very much on the edges of
these disciplines and I think you know
the sorts of you know the field is very
much emerging now this sort of field
that you might say yeah the social life
of climate change or however you want to
think about it it's still kind of being
pieced together so you know people
working in environmental media and
mental humanities eco media the apologi
sociology of climate change
okay I'm speaking to a public health at
the public health conference and like a
week and then to our clan scape
architects at Harvard next week so every
time I get a talk I feel like I'm kind
of trying to you know in a way to figure
out what I'm doing I just see which
audiences respond and how they kind of
frame the work and it's definitely a an
issue for the job market that yeah
hopefully all the the wise faculty in
the room can only work on over the
course of the next couple of years but
yeah it's tricky I think it's you know
when when you come to a I did not I did
not come into my ph.d program thinking I
would write about this I mean sandy
hadn't happened I didn't know anything
about climate change I didn't really
think about the environment I had worked
on the role of visual culture and urban
redevelopment and
kind of public art and I displacement
activism and so yeah I wound up doing a
very different project which I think
happens when you charging all the way
back to like a return to something in
your work if you have to deal with yeah
I mean I think one of the conversations
or questions came about like climate
deniers are kind of a red herring I mean
I think there's you know there's a super
well-funded
industry manufacturing doubt about this
topic but even in places where that's
that's not the case there's a great book
called living in denial written by a
sociologist an ethnographer calm carry
no regard and she went to this village
in Norway that has like the highest you
know they're off the charts in terms of
individual knowledge and belief in
climate change like everyone knows a ton
about climate change everyone believes
deeply in climate change and is really
deeply freaked out about climate change
and she went and she lived in this
village during a time when you know they
couldn't have enough snow for their kind
of ski based economy to function they
were suffering kind of huge local
impacts and
she realized that no one was talking
about climate change and that actually
it wasn't really any different than when
she was in the u.s. even though people
privately believed and we're concerned
and knew a lot about it it was not seen
as a public issue and it was not and
essentially it didn't matter in terms of
their actions that people believed in it
people were not you know it was not seen
as a local issue this is she writes
about the local newspaper there and the
role of that people didn't see it as
something to write letters to the editor
about her organized school walkouts
about and you know why did it not become
kind of the focus of local action the
way maybe you know the iraq war where
you saw similarly kind of a distant
issue that you could imagine on a local
level you can't you don't have control
over but that's the focus of a lot of
activism so that's when a climate March
was a big deal but in some way I think
the denial is much more kind of systemic
and in the New York case I mean you have
Mayor Michael Bloomberg who's you know a
huge advocate in terms of getting
mitigation on the agenda and getting
climate change on the agenda and really
a leader in that but then he's also
really invested in waterfront
development and kind of I mean you could
argue that if you mitigate fast enough
maybe you can have you can protect some
of this waterfront development but you
have different kinds of denial that are
that are operating always and I'm
supposed to be on a panel about climate
change denial at the Anthropology
meetings in a few weeks so speak to me
in a few weeks and I'll have like
written down enough to know what I think
good more
[Music]
[Applause]